all right today's topic if you guys
can't tell preacher's decided to shave
off his dreads so
welcome to the team how you feeling out
there
are you feeling all right i mean
everything i've been having you know
what the hell spiders yeah yeah whatever
it is what it is
i've been you know
sometimes you gotta actually you gotta
change your [ __ ] how long have you had
your hair for or had past tense
fifteen years fifteen yeah my eyes
supposed to be longer because the first
person that my hair didn't do them
properly she was pulling too much so i
had to list at least a foot of hair so
my hair was supposed to be like a foot
longer and you know whatever just i
don't know at some point you won't be
like [ __ ] rapunzel out here with your
dreads do you
you wear a hat before so when i saw you
come in today with a hat i said oh yo
this is this is not my hair because my
hair is not my hair don't it's not in
the way of the head i didn't feel the
first thing you know i don't feel the
first thing it's weird you just rub it
first
the best part you go outside you feel a
break
on your scalp huh and you'll be like
i've never been touched there before
exactly
please take me out to dinner before you
do that
right yo yeah it's yeah but i've i've
had hair before last time i had my bald
head when i was like 18.
whole [ __ ]
you know the difference between you is
what when i had long hair i couldn't be
bothered
you'd make a lot of efforts to make yeah
which i think is the right way to do it
people like why don't you grab your hair
you have such a nice hair i'm like
i can't be bothered no it's work yeah
there's a lot of [ __ ] that you you it's
worth it you don't give a [ __ ] about you
it's worse other than making sure it was
moisturized and my scalp was good i
didn't care to do anything else but
[ __ ] even that's work you gotta
partition everything oil that [ __ ] up
make sure you use the right everything
it's too much yeah i'm good i thought
yeah i've gotta grow my head but you
like taking care of that yeah so that's
how you gotta do it that's why you gotta
do it so whatever what do you guys think
you guys like preach with this new look
i mean i don't really give a [ __ ]
whether you like it or not because i
didn't do this [ __ ] for you
so
if you don't like it thanks before the
fans can you show them your scout yeah
of course
fight [ __ ]
got it
i got
it how many of them believe that [ __ ]
how many of you some of you probably
spin natural cereal right now be like
dave i shouldn't they're probably
writing some [ __ ] oh my god man man shut
the [ __ ] up anyways it's not that it's
stupid it's not it's not that it's not
that important you're like come down yes
it's all my hair i didn't cut them they
all fit in there depending on the
hairstyle i got they either look like i
have a high top on or they down to my
back it is what it is but no i didn't
cut my [ __ ]
stupid but you thought i cut my [ __ ]
when i got
i'm like [ __ ] with dress can't wear
hats yeah they can well i didn't know
that yeah yeah they can they can
like you know if you didn't know now you
know